[Music]
we made some pretty public mistakes and
we need to own them i think it's really
important to understand the great work
of this agency but also to admit to
areas where we needed to improve we owe
that to the american people
yeah after trying to control our lives
for three years the cdc now says whoops
sorry we we screwed that one up director
rachelle wilinsky admitting her agency
dropped the ball on the pandemic big
time saying the cdc failed to meet the
moment and calling their own guidance
confusing and overwhelming yeah no
kidding
but don't worry woliske claims
everything will all be under control
soon as uh with an agency-wide reset
and lord of the lockdowns dr fauci
himself also poking his head out to
defend the organization
when i think they should be commended in
the fact
particularly dr wolinski realizing and
recognizing
the shortcomings that have been there
for quite a long time long anti-dating
dr walensky's tenure so i'm actually
optimistic
that given the fact that the problems
have now been recognized that there's a
pathway
to making a very good organization much
better
yeah negan it sounds like uh they're
saying a bunch of nothing like i i have
a short memory but i remember the cdc
absolutely saying one thing and then
another and saying one thing and then
another and all they're saying now is
you know we're bad at communicating
um why is she still there
can i volunteer to fire her right now
you're fired you're fired get out tony
fauci is leaving right get out all i
remember is march of last year which was
like
i mean i'm really upset about what the
future looks like this woman and all the
people i love the it was an
infrastructure problem our public health
infrastructure in the country was not up
to the task no you weren't
and we no it's you i screwed up i set
children back
uh
their entire lives in terms of learning
because they were kept out of school
unnecessarily for a year and a half even
longer than that they never ran the risk
of con
like contracting grave illness or even
spreading it to adults but they closed
down schools because randy weingarten at
the american federation of teachers told
him to
how about just phone giving uh call in
say the parents of children who killed
themselves or tried to commit suicide
because they were locked away from their
friends
how about apologizing to all the people
who were fired across the country
teachers and firefighters and health
care workers because they didn't get the
vaccine which again only protects you
from severe illness doesn't protect
anybody else these people need to be
fired
they need to burn the entire cdc down
and start all over not literally jessica
katie i guess we're gonna bring in a
bureaucrat from the uh from obama's
generation to come in and fix things but
when you look into this they've spent
tens of thousands of dollars
not teaching wolinski how to lead but
just basic basically consulting on how
to communicate that she is a leader i
think they just need to find a little
bit of humanity and common sense uh when
the cdc had the science they made the
decision to follow the political science
on a number of things these guidelines
were not just confusing or inconsistent
they were inhumane and criminal and
cruel you had people dying alone in
nursing homes you had people dying alone
in hospital beds because they wouldn't
let you go visit your loved ones in the
hospital good women giving birth alone
without their husbands and separated
from their babies if someone tested
positive for covid in the maternity
wards they kept schools closed for years
and we know now that was a direct result
of them listening to the teachers unions
and then you had the crusade from the
president of the united states and the
full force of the federal government to
try and run the unvaccinated the great
unclean out of society to get them fired
to keep them out of restaurants to keep
them out of workplaces and that's
despicable and so when it comes to what
we know
we knew early on what the science was
and they refused to follow it on a
number of these issues and people's
lives were changed in very terrible ways
as a result greg is there is there less
public trust in the cdc or the fbi right
now is it kind of a race to the bottom i
don't know i mean
i would prefer i want to give them some
advice right i have what do i have her i
have five suggestions five suggestions
they if because it's a reset and in a
reset they should listen to all points
of view and number one you should uh
make a commitment to being apolitical
don't talk to the teachers unions reject
the woke so that just keep stay away
from politics that means turning off the
tv we'll live with that don't chase zero
risk because you'll end up undermining
all of society zero chasing zero risk
making sure there's no risk at all is
why they put sand in skateboard parks
and why no one no one could see their
loved ones right you should put medical
science in front of legal consequences
that's why we're shut down right
everybody's everybody's more scared of
lawyers and lawsuits than they are of
disease again if you're chasing zero
risk that that means that puts you into
the insurance companies and the lo and
the lawyers and you end up in some kind
of like self-made prison
then focus on high-risk patients first
which which allows you to avoid the
blanket recommendations for everyone
people have different risk uh profiles
an obese 35 year old is way different
than a 35 year old gym rat unfortunately
we weren't allowed to say that because
we were too scared and i actually have
to say it is the last point is it's okay
to change course science does that all
the time you could find out in a matter
of weeks that you were wrong but you
have to do it for the data reasons
not for the politics and not for fear
you you you want to do it if the risk
reduction is worth it and makes sense i
think i should run this cdc i've never
heard
anything again took a match
jessica real quick for two years we we
as conservatives were told we were
playing partisan politics by critiquing
things like the cdc and now they're kind
of admitting to it uh so do they need to
apologize to us as well well she did you
were allowed to tune into cbs it's also
it's a free networking tv doesn't go
there
really it's a terrestrial channel it
definitely does um
so
the big thing that people will never
forget is what happened to kids i think
that everyone can kind of stand what
happened to adults who you know weren't
i'm just saying that setting kids back
especially when we knew things about the
science of transmission outside and that
started very early that was in the
summer right that we knew that you could
eat outside which is why now here in new
york city we have permanent outdoor
dining right because that was something
that was safe um so
that's something that i i personally
don't think will be forgiven on any of
these levels but it is important in
these conversations to always consider
the fact and yes most of them had
complications most were the elderly but
over a million americans died because of
this it's not some invented thing you
know that was never going to hurt
anybody and yes the science changes and
people should move along with it and say
well from what we know now this is our
best recommendation and those words
would have helped so much in temporary
reset involves new faces and i see dr
fauci all over the tv
can i say two words china virus
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else